did you know World of Warcraft was one
studied by real scientists Once Upon a
Time in 2005 a programming oversight and
wow led to a debuff from a raid boss
being spread further than they thought
possible really long story short a raid
boss hawar the soul flare would infect
nearby players with corrupted blood bad
news is that poor little hunter pets if
unsummoned while infected would still
have it when resummoned outside of the
raid so an infectious pet meant an
infectious owner which meant an
infectious player base and it wasn't
until a hard reset that Azeroth found
peace the epidemic went so deep that
quarantine zones had to be established
people broadcasted hotspots and healers
acted like actual Medics yes there was a
fullblown pandemic response and that
response caused epidemiologists to
explore and research the corrupted blood
incident to see if it could be used as a
research model for real life pandemics
and I'm not going to let that happen
again